THIS IS THE SHIT!!
So it starts off like,
“That copter was taken down years ago!”
*copter noises*
And then they’re like, “Get out of the copter or we’ll shoot!”
And then he’s like
*transforming noises*
And it’s a Transformer, you know, it’s just—it’s so cool!
And he’s just like
*shooting fools up*
And everyone’s like, AH! AH! AH!
(Monkey!)
And there’s this kid, you know, he’s trying to get laid, and so he buys this car.
And it’s like the coolest car in the world! It, like, knows how to pick up chicks!
How can a car know how to pick up chicks?
So he’s driving around, and he picks up this hot chick and stuff,
the car’s doing, like, all the work, I don’t know how it does it.
And then there’s this lame line, you know,
“There’s more to you than meets the eye,”
and everyone, *annoyed groaning*, you know, ok.
But then the car is like, *transforming noises* and it’s a Transformer too!
And he’s sending out this signal from his stomach, like the Bat-signal, I don’t know what that’s about.
And then there’s this little robot that kinda sounds like a Gremlin.
*Gremlin chittering*
And they’re just like, “DIE, BITCH!”
*gunfire*
And then these asteroids are like *whoosh*!
Boom. Boom. Boom.
And the kid’s like, “50 years from now, you may look back, and you’ll wish you got in that car.”
It’s like “aww”, you know? (More like "bleh")
And then a truck comes in, and it’s OPTIMUS PRIME!
HOLY FUCK! OPTIMUS PRIME IS IN THIS MOVIE!!
And of course, he goes, *transforming* and it’s OPTIMUS PRIME! GODDAMN!!
And he’s got the same voice and everything!
And he’s HUGE! He’s like gi-fucking-gantic!
And the good guys are the Autobots, and they kick ass!
And one of ‘em’s a Hummer! I’m totally buying a Hummer today!
And then there’s the DECEPTICONS.
You got like a tank,
you got like a *sudden jumpcut* airplane,
you got like a police car.
I always knew police were evil, I knew it, I had a feeling!
And they’re like, “We gotta stop Megatron!”
And Megatron is like fucking HUGE!
He’s like this huge… big… GRR!
And there’s a huge battle in the city, and you just wouldn’t believe it! Everything’s there!
*gun fire*
*copter noises*
Boom! AH! Boom! AH!
And all the people are like,
AAAAHHH! AAAAAAHHHHHHHHH!!
And then they’re like, “Protect the Cube!”
*plane*
*gun fire*
And the girl’s like, “Whatever happens today, I’m glad I stepped in that car.”
And everyone’s like, "ugh", I mean, *sobbing*
And then they’re like, “It’s just you and me, Megatron!”
Boom! *grunting* Boom! You bitch! Boom!
*explosion*
AH! AH! AH!
Ugh! Oomph! Mmph!
*girly scream*
Ugh!
Boom!
Oomph!
Ugh!
Boom!
*Michael Bay's ego*
And then it’s like, “If any Autobots are listening, there is more than meets the eye.”
And then it was like, “The End”, and everyone’s like,
“WHOO! YEAH! YEAH! YEAH! YEAH!!!”
…So it was good.
*thud*
*Captions provided using transcript from Channel Awesome Wiki (and best guess from ears) as reference. NC rocks*